[Music]
hello my name is israeli root I work
as a cloud strategy inguinal in google
cloud and today I am going to talk about cloud
machine learning engine google is a
company focused on machine learning
in google search when you make
any query the search engine must
know exactly  what do you need and it must
respond with exactly what it is looking
for to be able to do this
google needs machine learning but what
is machine learning when they talk
about machine learning we understand that it is
something similar to this we have on the one hand a
lot of data on the other hand we have a
mathematical or very sophisticated method
that somehow converts that data into
knowledge and the results are almost
magical, they give us an answer without knowing
very well how, but it works,
however, in reality, machine learning
is much more like this, there are many
more steps than simply  remove the
model remove the model is complex but
until you reach the step of being able to remove the
mod  elo much more
needs to be done we need to clearly define what
question we want to answer what are
the objectives of this model we need to
collect the data many times
we don't even have the data we
need to solve this problem we
need to prepare it this usually takes a
lot of time in a
project
then it arrives  to the stage of creating a
model itself, which is let's say the most
beautiful stage is the one that we normally understand
as machine learning and then comes to
evaluating refining the model and putting it into
production making it work is not
a simple task
all these tasks all these
additional stages that must be done
suppose a lot of work, so
when we understand that doing machine
learning is to make our
machine learning model, we have to understand
that it is much more than this, that it is much
more than the code of this model, we must
do many more, many more  steps that
are precisely those that cover that
cloud machine reads  rning engine we have
tools for the
data collection and evaluation part there are
tools for fitur engineering
we have tools to evaluate and
monitor the model to automate
the training to train the
scale model imagine the google search engine
how much volume of data it has to
process to  being able to answer
our queries the entire web is
an unimaginable volume and then we have
to be able to use this model
both in bach mode
and this requires that the model be
put into production and that it can
answer these queries queries
this doesn't  it's a simple task
let's see cloud machine learning the
first step we're going to do is see the
notepad notebook interface
the notepad is an
executable document that allows us to refine
our model to integrate on top of the
model until we find the
right model  let's see how levin is used in
cloud machine and let's start
using cloud ma  chine learning in
through the google cloud console for this
we go to the navigation menu on the
left we look for the
artificial intelligence section
and in digital intelligence we have a
management that puts the engine and here
we look for notepad which is the first
tool  what are we going to see in this
video that is in english in english is
notebooks we can say notes
indistinctly so here we are going to create
a new instance with this we are going to
create a new virtual machine
prepared to start doing machine
learning when we click here in new
instance we can create a
virtual machine that comes already preconfigured
tense context the flow compay torch or
we can configure it in more detail
we are going to start a machine with
tensor flow that we can use to
initialize it with gpu but we are going to
initialize a standard machine
there are some  how many options are we going to
leave the default options for this
example
now we have to wait  rar for the
machine to be
created we already have the virtual machine created and
when creating the virtual machine google
cloud has also created an instance of
jupiter lab and has also installed tensor
flow if we had chosen a gpu it
would have installed all the drivers and
had left it configured  tensor flow by
torch to use the gpu without having to
do anything else so now that
we have it started here we are going to open
here jupiter la and we are going to start using
a notebook with tensor flow and want
to see how our virtual machine works
with matilde
this interface is jupiter it comes pre-
configured with a series of
additional modules for example we see here below
on the right that we can use tensor
board
if we had any model entering
with tensor board directly in a
tab we could see the fervor without
having to launch the hand we see  also
here this git repositories symbol
we could automatically clone the
repository here just put  do the
url in this tool for now in
this video we are going to use one of the
tutorials that come here
preconfigured
with the virtual machine we are going to use this one
you want and we are going to see this
basic classification that is a
fairly complex model despite the name
then we already have the notebook open here
the notebook is an executable document it
has cells that can
contain text code formulas images
and we are executing the document formula
formula cell cell sorry we are going to
start with the first cells and we are going
to start with the model then
we import tensor flow  we see that it
has version 113 which is the same as the one
with which the virtual machine was installed it
had to be this one we are going to download the
data
we have already downloaded the data in this
data it is a classification problem
we have different categories for
classification we have seen that  we have
here photographs of pieces of clothing and what
we are going to do is a photograph of
a piece  of clothes a shoe classify it
and classify it within these ten
possible categories as the categories
are texts we need to
introduce in the model a tensor a
matrix that has more than two dimensions
we have to somehow transform
these numbers
we have decided that this is the
category scale for example
t-shirts is category number 0 and
bags is category number 8 this
selection is arbitrary and could be
any other the model doesn't change
because we changed this let's take a
look at the data we have 60,000
images of  with 28 28 pixels by 28
pixels
we have that here there have to be
60,000 labels to train which is a
model that we are going to use a neural network
and supervised learning we
also need some labels for each of
the inputs for color of the images
here we see a  example that the labels
are numbers between 0 and 9 the
test set has 10,000 images of 28  x 28
and obviously there must also be 10,000
labels and now we are ready
we are going to take a look at the
data first to clarify ourselves because this is one
of the images that we have for example
because here we see that it is a
sports boot a shoe
we see in the  image here that the
numerical values of the tensor go from 0 to 255 f
r a better so that from the numer
cal point of view the model train
better we are going to scale these numbe
s so that they go from 0 to 1 and avoid, for e
ample, problems with calculations with very
arge numbers  large let's scale the data now
let's take a look at the
data again after scaling
here we have several images when
rescaling it changes let's say the
color scale goes from 0 to 1 they are
black and white images but it affects the
image  we have the same shape the same
pieces jerseys t-shirts shoes etc and
now we are going to build the model this
is the net of a that we are going to train it
has simply two layers and the cap  At the
outset
we are not going to stop at because we have
decided that it is a very simple model
but we are going to see what can work
we decide on the optimization method we are going to
train
monitoring the cures and the accuracy of the
model and finally we are going to train it
we are going to enter the  for five epochs
here we see that each epoch begins to train
in this case with this example because it
takes about 10 seconds
the model is already finishing training
we see that it has taken about 10 seconds
each epoch we are training in cpu
we can also train in gpu and
we would have  configured the
virtual machine with a gpu and it should have gone
faster these ten seconds we are going to
evaluate the model that we have obtained
we continue executing cells
we are going to check to see how much the
cure is if in the set of tests it
is 86 8% 0.6 868  very good very good to
cures and we are going to see the projections
we have calculated all the forecasts
we are going to check a hand of the first
prediction  So we see that it gives us a vector of
numbers the position where the
maximum value of this vector is is the maximum
probability of that category is the
probability of that category is maximum
we are going to see what that is with a country because
we see that it is 9 and  we are going to see if the
correct model does not, because the
test category of that image was 9 in this
case the correct model obviously this
is a very cave way of evaluating the
model we are going to try to do it in
a more visual way we have here a couple of
image a couple of functions to
graphically represent the
predictions here we see that it is an
ankle boot the forecast is an
ankle boot we see here the probability between
0 and 1 this is the maximum category 9
in this case well okay let's see
another other  item in this case it is another type
of model a women's sports shoe
another category is in blue it
means that the model has been successful
let's finally see a few more
because here we see in this case  o has accepted
in all if you repeat this example with a
virtual machine on google cloud platform
with the same virtual machine the
soldiers could be slightly
different you have to take into account for
example that the initialization of the model
is random and in a specific case it can
give results  different with
different executions then we are going to
check how the model works if
we only wanted to predict an image
nothing more
we are going to have an image that this
image as the first of all is 28
x 28 we add it to a tensor the models
in which the  flow have to
work on tensors we can't use
an image we just have to add
an additional dimension to it as maybe a
bit redundant because it doesn't change anything
only the structure but otherwise
the model won't work because it doesn't have
the right format we see here the vector
of  projections let's draw draw
this graphically and see that you got
the category of n right
again
ankle boot and here we should
get a 9 to say that it is until
everything is correct very well we have already
trained in our first model in
cloud machine learning in jean using
a virtual machine with a
notebook interface created simply using the
interface  from google cloud platform and
now if you want you can
also train your own model with your own
machine using google cloud platform your
gmail account and free
or not